[Musique]
bonjour à l'allégorie
bonjour dhimmi bonjour à tous bonjour
simon jean joseph bonjour à limbe
aujourd'hui me pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas je ne vais pas refaire
votre palmarès il y assez éloquent en
résumé vous êtes champion de sport
automobile et samedi sort au cinéma jean
jo si votre surnom l'histoire d'un
champion un documentaire que qui vous
est consacré il est réalisé par fabien
duflot nous allons y revenir mais est ce
que vous vous rendez compte si mon sens
joseph que vous êtes l'un des sportifs
voir le sportif le plus aimé à la
martinique
2 si vous le dites j'en suis ravi mais
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est un
grand honneur pour moi que d'avoir ce
portrait qui qui retrace ma carrière je
dois avouer que ça fait un peu bizarre
j'ai présenté d'ailleurs sur ce portrait
à une partie de mes équipes ya pas
longtemps mais c'est la première fois je
le voyais sur un écran un peu plus grand
que celui d'un ordinateur et oui ça m'a
beaucoup touché
je me souviens des courses on va voir
sinon joseph on va pas obligatoirement
voilà pouvoir la course on va voir si
mon joseph c'est vrai j'avais un
pilotage assez spectaculaire g vous
savez je suis un j'étais passionné jeune
j'avais un style un peu particulier
toujours en glisse ce qui m'a valu
d'ailleurs de perdre un peu de temps au
début de ma carrière parce que pour les
vite il faut être il faut il vraiment
une conduite très très propre et c'est
vrai que ce style particulier a fait que
les spectateurs et même beaucoup me voir
passer au bord des routes donc oui c'est
des souvenirs extraordinaires je
n'oublie évidemment pas et je n'ai
jamais oublié le début de ma carrière et
on en tire de cette mairie par exemple
marrer c'est le premier à livrer que
j'ai gagné de ma ma carrière de ma vie
c'était d'ailleurs en avril 90 quelque
chose comme ça
donc voilà j'ai effectivement
traîner beaucoup pendant le coin aussi
dans les routes du nord comme le fond
saint denis de chou chant flore etc et
toutes ces routes mon m'ont permise de
m'améliorer d'aller ensuite en
guadeloupe puis en championnat de france
en championnat du monde on est c est
donc voilà c'est une formidable histoire
c'est extrêment bien moi je jouais quand
je me retourne ses jeux enfin voila je
plutôt très fier du parcours qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie de pratiquer ce
sport
je crois comme tout petit garçon petit
jeu mais j'aimais les voitures
ensuite mon frère et mon père ont fait
de la course malheureusement comme on le
sait ou peut-être certains ne savent pas
mon frère c'est décédé en course
automobile donc ça a été un changement
de vie sains frais incomplet à la course
c'est un choc à l'époque déjà perdre un
frère c'est un choc le perdant plus sous
mes yeux c'est encore plus compliqué et
puis ça me allemand mes parents
n'étaient plus du tout favorable à ce
que je fasse de la course donc ça a été
ça a été un vrai challenge un vrai défi
mais je lai avant tout fait je voudrais
très clair je le doivent avant tout fait
parce que j'étais passionné parce que je
voulais faire ça et il n'y avait aucune
sorte ni de vengeance ni de prolongement
de mon frère ni de quoi que ce soit
j'avais déjà à booster quand même
je ne pense pas que sa fin boostés je
pense pas que ce soit le juge terme
samassa m'a certainement
j'avais franchement je n'arrive pas à
trouver j'ai été très peiné ça a été un
énorme changement ne dit d'ailleurs dans
le documentaire gens parlent assez
clairement et je m'en serais vraiment
passer maintenant certains disent que si
ça ne cet événement n'avait pas eu lieu
j'aurais peut-être fait différemment je
sais pas en tout cas j'étais déjà
passionné très tôt très jeune j'écoutais
à l'époque sur les ondes am la
j'écoutais radio monte carlo
et j'écoutais la nuit du turini en
décalage horaire puisque voilà et je
passais une partie de la nuit
discrètement sans que mes parents
n'entendent à écouter ce qui se passait
en championnat du monde dont j'étais
déjà très passionné et ce qui vous a
séduit dans ce projet de documentaire
pourquoi vous avez dit oui
c'est une anecdote tout à fait enfin je
me suis retrouvé un jour à dans une
réunion avec des gens il ya quelqu'un à
qui parler avec des personnes il ya
quelqu'un qui dit mais vous connaissez
pas simon jean-joseph les gens du bruit
on connaît la personne et oui mais c'est
un grand champion et je suis plutôt
quelqu'un d'assez modeste et je dis
maintenant mon sac en main laisse tomber
enfin voilà et cette personne me dit
mais tu devrais faire un portrait sur
toi je dis bah non pas quand même fait
enfin jeu on a tous un peu d'ego mais
quand même et cette personne m'a pris au
mot en disant ben tiens je vais
réfléchir pourquoi pas faire un portrait
je dis ok puis quelques jours après
cette personne m'a rappelé en me disant
ben voilà dans le cadre de lancement
d'une plate forme s'appelle ou van go on
va
on va faire un portrait autour de toi et
de ta carrière donc j'ai été plutôt très
touché ça s'est passé il ya 7 en avril
2021 ou en mars 2021 les premières
images ont été tournées en avril 2021 et
le film s'était enfin le documentaire
s'est terminée il ya quelques temps
voilà donc voilà ce qui s'est passé le
tournage est il facile malgré la période
qu'ovide le tournage a été
alors les images à la martinique
notamment jeu le jour j'en suis enfin
elles sont belles mais mais je suis un
peu déçu dans le sens où ou s'il y avait
un peu de brume de sable à cette période
et c'est vrai c'est un documentaire qui
aurait pu d'un côté touristique faire
rêver aussi des gens parce que c'est un
documentaire qui passera en europe puis
un peu partout dans les dom etc mais non
ce qu'a été ce qui est ce qui est
difficile c'est de se livrer vraiment
c'est d'être le plus sincère possible
dans et puis ce qui était difficile
c'est de revenir enfin la sincérité
n'est pas difficile mais ça fait
remonter des émotions ça fait revenir
sur des souvenirs magnifiques mais aussi
sur des souvenirs douloureux et puis et
puis baisse qui a été intéressant pour
moi c'est de découvrir ceux des coûts
sociaux de se documenter parce que moi
je n'ai fait que répondre à des
questions qui m'ont été posées
évidemment j'ai donné une liste de
personnes pour que ce réalisateur puisse
rencontrer des gens il a rencontré une
partie pas tout et moi je n'ai vu que le
document final et dans le document final
je n'ai strictement rien changé
en tout cas je me suis pas permis de
faire quoi que ce soit je les desserts
l'état brut il ya juste eu un changement
sur une entre la première la dernière
version sur un séquençage qu'on a
considéré qu'il valait mieux qu'ils
passent au début plutôt qu'à la fin
voilà mais sinon le concernant et
concernant des ceux qui ont les donneurs
d'ordres il n'y a eu aucun changement
est ce qu'il ya un message à travers ce
documentaire que vous souhaitez faire
passer
si je commence à faire passer le message
avant que les gens d'aller voir le film
safa le clown en spirale voilà mes
selon certaines personnes on peut penser
que c'est quelque chose d'inspirant
c'est toujours difficile de parler de
soi j'ai une histoire assez atypique je
suis
déjà à la base mes parents j'avais ma
mère était hollandaise mon père était
martiniquais mes parents se sont
rencontrés dans les années 50 dans nos
états unis en martinique et aux états
unis dans les années cinquante et une
petite houle en deux c'était peu commun
vous savez qu'il ya des réalisations de
la ségrégation était c'était encore bien
mais bien présent aux états unis mes
parents se sont mariés et non avec
beaucoup de difficulté mon frère
d'ailleurs est né là bas aux états unis
donc je suis issu d'une famille un peu
atypique mais qui m'a qui a été très
inspirante qui a été très enrichissante
face c'était une éducation magnifique
pour moi malheureusement à l'âge de 14
ans il ya eu ce drame familial et ma vie
a basculé changé et des choses non plus
été les mêmes pour autant j'ai réussi à
rebondir et je reste un éternel
optimiste face à au fait qu'il faut
savoir rebondir comment vous
allez enfin pu parler de l'homme du site
royal comment vous avez vécu avec ce
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles en martinique avec ce
vote le pen comment vous je pense qu'il
faut il faut l'entendre en tout cas il
faut il faut en être bien conscient
comment je les ai vécus comment vous
l'analysez
je ne suis pas un spécialiste en tout
cas
je suis un citoyen qui a de la mémoire
je n'ai pas
je suis un peu surpris donc on passe
d'un extrême à un autre cette terre les
pays tiers des portes qui cimetière de
cas porter les fans les saisies à des
glisses on pense que c'est un vote
clairement contestataires c'est un vote
qui met en avant une souffrance et une
incompréhension je pense qu'il ya
vraiment quand je dis une souffrance et
c'est dans la communication je reste
convaincu qu'à la martinique aujourd'hui
nous avons de vrais problèmes d'échangé
de communication et que nous avons tous
mais tous à tout niveau des efforts à
faire pour essayer d'être plus tolérant
plus communicants essayer justement de
d'aller vers le meilleur on a perdu
notre bien évidente vivre ensemble
personnellement je me bats tous les
jours pour je sais pas si on l'a perdu
mais je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
de problématiques qui exacerbe des gens
je pense qu'il ya des choses qui n'ont
peut-être pas été réglée
il nous avons un vrai problème
aujourd'hui et de dont j'ai l'impression
qu'on a on fait un recul c'est pas
l'impression il ya un vrai recul
aujourd'hui sur l'éducation sur
l'instruction sur qu'est ce qui vous
fait noël et les chiffres les stats on
revient d'illettrisme ce qui n'existait
pas en martinique depuis le savez ça
avait plutôt minime largement est
fortement diminué nos sources
d'information aujourd'hui ont beaucoup
évolué et changé on entend quelque chose
donc
partir comme on l'entend on peut penser
que c'est une certitude non comme vous
le savez vous êtes bien passé pour
savoir qu'aujourd'hui la communication
et
aux murs des réseaux sociaux sur herman
l'affluence des réseaux sociaux a
beaucoup changé la donne mais à tous
niveaux pas que politique à tous niveaux
pour toute information on l'a bien vu
aujourd'hui avec la problématique qu
vide ça a été ça a été un drame ça nous
a énormément divisé moi je regarde au
sein de ma propre famille ça a été un
jeu le dire je ne pense que je pense que
tout martiniquais et toute personne
certainement en france a été confronté à
cette problématique
justement vous ai parlé du coup vide le
coc vite comment vous avez vécu deux ans
deux ans de privation du temps de
restriction sap a été difficile pour
vous vous êtes d'ailleurs chef
d'entreprise vous êtes le directeur du
de la marina du marin comment vous avez
vécu ce
jeudi à face à un problème comme celui
ci il faut il faut enfin moi j'ai essayé
d'être résilient j'essayais de d'abord
de faire face et de trouver des
solutions au fur et à mesure on personne
ne savait au départ on avait quoi on
avait trois ou dix cas au départ et on a
fermé on a tous fermés aujourd'hui on en
a deux mille et on vit avec donc je sais
c'est pas une critique c'est juste un
constat et et je peux comprendre on a
fait trop au début je suis certainement
pas je crois que personne ne savait où
on allait et personnellement je serais
très mal placé pour dire si on aime bien
ou mal fait un mot à un moment selon moi
en tout cas dans ma vision des choses il
ya des gens qui prennent des décisions
elles sont certainement critiquable mais
il faut bien que celui rien de pire que
de ne pas prendre de décision donc à
partir du moment où on en prend
évidemment on se fait taper dessus mais
mais mais voilà enfin moi en tout cas
j'ai je me suis adapté à la situation
étant quelqu'un d'assez résilient jeunes
et oui c'est ça pas été simple mais mais
voilà deux ans ben maintenant c'est
derrière nous et comme d'habitude je
regarde devant je regarde pas derrière
mais c'est sûr que ça a laissé des
traces a fait remonter un certain nombre
de problématiques je suis plus sur cette
problématique là si vous voulez la
martinique connaissait déjà des
difficultés et aujourd'hui le coville
n'a pas arrangé les choses sacrées et
plus d'inégalités
évidemment que ça a créé peut-être c'est
pas que ça crée des plus d'inégalités ça
fait certainement remonter des
problématiques dont tout le monde
n'était pas conscient je pourrais pas
partir je pense qu'à la martinique nous
avons des vrais problèmes enfin il ya
des gens qui souffrent il ya des gens
qui ont des difficultés il ya des gens
il ya déjà il ya des gens effectivement
kiki qui n'arrivent pas à manger où est
sa plus en plus ça c'est évident d'un
autre côté je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
aussi un langage vrai et il faut qu'on
puisse mettre les choses à plat pour
faire avancer le schmilblick